hi everybody i'm ryan right i'm dan
syverud we're gonna watch the trailer
for up another wait hold on this is a
game trailer dan haha it is complete
wait seriously yeah the only the only
time you wear the hat is for game
reviews not everything no but if it's a
game review I have to wear the hat okay
you should wash your head I really
should watch my game we're gonna watch
has been highly requested
it's called hatred I don't think I know
much about this game I'm really excited
to find out about this game yeah let's
let's do this let's do it to it that's
the quote from an extreme goofy movie
it's good Jim now is stick together it's
good to the best of buds forever you get
it Ellie analogous my name is not
important this important is what I
wanted to
arches maybe she would work steamers
caucus
and I exploited two time
life is worth saving
we've as many as I
and it's time for me to do oh my god
crusade begins here
haha
oh goodness oh my god this is a [ __ ]
insane
it's like the purge
[ __ ] do we get away with that how did
this get made he's murdering innocent
people the [ __ ] was that
that is so [ __ ] extreme didn't I [ __ ]
what I thought out of all video games we
can never get something I got man what
are you [ __ ] kidding me it's like
good girl
wait what okay with this we've accepted
all right it's [ __ ] oh my god [ __ ]
this
aah I literally could not believe what I
was watching it's one of those moments
where you truly forget a camera is
recording you're right it's just [ __ ]
insane I kind of want to play this just
for the giggle right there's a line
between what state Grand Theft Auto for
example obviously in that you can mow
down an entire Street of innocent people
yeah but that is not the core element
yeah but yeah there's like missions and
[ __ ] and this one it's like the mission
just [ __ ] as many people up as possum
yes I mean god wow that is one of the
most shocking things of medicine I like
I'm like honestly not okay with it no
I'm fine I just feel bad like I feel
gross watching that that's like really
bringing out the worst in someone oh
yeah it really is
you're like living by curiously through
a mass murder if there's ever a game for
anyone to go like this is a reason why
there are shootings yeah exactly
this is the reason no totally I
completely agree it's just flat out
about like killing beef I was waiting
for like the punchline yeah like like
it's like this is totally just like
[ __ ] like [ __ ] the world
blah there's no substitute it's like
it's weird I feel all these like
horrible things about it but this is a
part of me that's like I kind of admire
that you guys just went all out like
that it's not gonna be a fun game to
play I mean just looking at it like
you're shooting you're leaving like in
such brutal ways in such brutal ways
it's just well we did it we did it we
did it we did it we in America down the
toilet we did it no [ __ ] Amy you ruin
this country never never touching this
this should go into a vault and staler
to rot I gotta show this video people
it's the new shrek is love shrek is life
for me I got it show this video but I
don't think it's that far there's
something super magical about shrek is
love shrek is life
what's up Sally yeah yeah yeah there's
probably gonna be a lot of news stories
about horrible this game is and it's
great you guys reacting to it because
that could actually be a factor someone
wanting to interview you about why you
thought it was so horrible and why it's
like ruining our children well thanks
thank you I support the game I don't
know if the [ __ ] she's talking about Oh
looks fantastic it's like a game you
can't like physically get behind yeah
but it's gonna sell its I would say well
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects where
we offer orrible things like that to
watch along with us and you can
subscribe to Dan's gaming channel I'm
back I vote that damn plays hatred on
his chin no no no that's not happening
that's that's not happening but there
will be five nights at freddy's
featuring this guy yeah oh yeah let's
not forget about that
Szell's are an old house our whole hails
out sockies houses are during a trailer
reaction with Veronica she looks so
dirty minded and then looks so
disappointed when Ryan said shout outs I
freaking love to heart I think he meant
to say I freakin love you too yeah but
not you too the band us too Veronica and
I yeah that's cool that's cool that you
love us our relationship is mainly for
public display we like to use it to
capitalize more and it makes you know
like people are like Oh Ryan you know
he's perverted but he's also really
sweet so like it totally works in my
favor yeah afterwards she just slaps him
straight in the face and leaves yeah as
long as the camera is honest we are
getting along really well so thank you
so much for reminding me how terrible my
fake relationship is hahaha that's such
an evil lot Jovan Lee hello may I get a
shout out but I want you and Veronica to
be in the video game is let me see if I
can arrange this javonni wanted you to
say hiding oh yeah she's wearing she's
wearing her old Navy sweater that's hers
that's the size she picked that adult
extra-large
it's mine dan yeah you're adding to the
video thank you your comedy silent
striker 2:01 all Hales owls are yo Ryan
love your videos man shout me out if you
can but let's see if I can
do you uh to poop again a little bit
yeah
there you go to the bathroom cool
it with me